ladies and gentlemen because more
moderate voices are being drowned out by
folks on the fringes of the mosque
debate like that Pastor in Florida we
thought you should hear from the drivers
then of the uh the most extreme aspects
of this controversy I'm sure you
remember Malik shabaz who HS up the
small but aggressive New Black Panther
Party and this is Pamela Geller whose
group's very name is provocative enough
called stop islamization of America why
choose a name like stop is is there
islamization of America going on well
this this Mega mosque is part of it but
I just want to say a couple things well
first of all you have to answer my
question about islamization of America
what do you define as islamization of I
Define the US Treasury giving seminars
and Sharia finance a week after we
nationalized some banks I Define masking
the workplace imposing Muslim prayer
times on uh Union contracts imposing
Muslim prayer times on non-union workers
how about Hindi prayer time or Jewish
prayer time
they're not imposing it in the secular
Marketplace or the Public Square they're
not imposing it a woman Islam is being
treated differently than other religions
special being favored
by I'm sure that they would they would
argue that point but but of course
that's how they impose more of Islam but
you really think that there's some
sneaky plan to make our country an Islam
country s it's not a sneaky plan it's
it's encroaching Islamic supremacism and
this is what we stand against Islamic
supremacism yeah Islamic supremacism
who's we how many people in your group
well we have I guess 18,000 members on
Facebook we listen 18 members have
stopped islamization of America it's
only the separation of mosque and state
that's all it is like church and state I
mean a Prett let me get the other guest
you have several segments to make your
point uh but let me go to Malik I you
know we didn't come to fight either of
you but the last time we were together
Malik you mocked uh the 911 attacks some
video I showed you that you didn't know
was going to be seen shortly after 911
you were in front of other members of
the New Black Panther Party mocking the
attacks and seeming to support them do
you still feel that way no no that's
that's not true I have friends who have
family who passed in that building and
what I'm saying right now can you say
that one more time Malik I miss I have
friends I have friends who have family
who passed into the Twin Towers but what
I'm also saying is this is a point where
we can get more mature Beyond
emotionalism and also feel the pain of
the hund 50,000 innocent Muslims that
have directly or indirectly died as a
result of the wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan America is not becoming
Islamic supremacist ma'am America As
Time Magazine pointed out is
islamophobic and Muslims are being
treated like the blacks and the Indians
always have okay and I fear that Muslims
will will be on the road to
concentration camps if we don't put a
stop to the bigotry that's all right
conc ation camps is as crazy as
islamization of America head in that
direction I don't know about that uh and
I I doubt it seriously okay got to take
a card break coming up Pamela Geller
Malik shabaz uh my guests uh do you you
know we are not reporting on another
incident that happened at the White
House involving the the Quran because I
think we're just inciting more violence
I got it I got a note from a commander
in Afghanistan talking about another
demonstration that we have not yet shown
he says uh uh it's amazing what some
folks will do even after they know that
it potentially could have far-reaching
and damaging consequences this to our
troops in Afghanistan do you support
these acts of desecration of the Quran
the Muslim holy book no I I certainly
don't support the Quran Burning uh
clearly the antidote to bad speech is uh
you know not censorship not book burning
uh it's open discussion it's give and
take and the so you do not support will
ask these gross act do you condemn them
it's do you condemn them I do condemn
them but it is protected speech and I
certainly would wouldn't want to reward
the jihadists who were threatening
violent Jihad on the one hand on the
other hand I it needs to be stated that
it was not dueling rallies Heraldo we
had 30,000 people at our rally there was
maybe wait wait ACC to the cops you had
1500 go go to atlas shrug. comom and
you'll see the pictures no well I
welcome spatial scientists but what I'm
saying is is that that was 9/11 was
chosen because you know Daisy Khan said
that she was going to break ground on
the ground zero musque on September 11th
so it's not is this another Conspiracy
Theory May is it was in the New York it
was in the daily news and it was in USA
Today no it's not a conspiracy the
that's Malik shabaz do you
condemn the well let me put it this way
the ambassador to Pakistan said that he
would be in favor of moving that mosque
a couple of blocks do you also similarly
agree to a reasonable compromise that
can defuse this issue isue while
honoring all sides to this
debate I would not as an attorney I
would say that it it would create a
slippery slope and if the Muslims give
up their right of worship here they will
end up giving it up
everywhere why is it that if the Indians
were massacred let me ask you this
should we move what would you pay
for well I certainly wouldn't pay 20 but
youd pay North ofont I don't know I I'd
have to look at the building Heraldo but
I I really think if he could sell and if
he could sell for a little bit of a
profit I mean you know he's asking four
times what he paid give me a break if he
could sell for a little bit of a profit
make lots of friends in doing it go to
another location where you wouldn't have
the insensitivity I think it'd make so
many friends who would be a great thing
he turned a positive a real positive he
turned this into a real positive Noel
nickp Republican strategist you agree
with the Donald don't you oh yeah
absolutely you know I do
and so you think you heard the Pakistani
ambassador I hope it sounds like and we
have heard as I've reported from the
other side from not the other side from
the uh the uh developers that they would
sell for a price it seems to me the
beginnings of a compromise might be
emerging I'm praying for it
anyway then we'll go to
Malik all I'll answer them M go ahead I
think it's absolutely ridiculous that
they would put a price tag like that and
and make a profit off uh not even being
compassionate I mean first of all you
have to ask yourself you know is is the
mosque generally is it going to be an
asset to the community no it's not going
to be an asset to to the community and
the other thing is what construction
worker if they don't manage to sell this
what construction worker is actually
going to want to work on that project
who are they going to find no New Yorker
that I know Malik first of all go ahead
well first of all the Imam has of that
mosque and Islamic Learning Center has
been working in that Community for years
wouldn't it also be sensitive to move
every Church from every location where
so-called Christians massacred millions
of Indians in New York in the Trail of
Tears and to move Church Native
Americans uh yeah native I'm talking
about Native Americans or Indians we
should move churches off the land where
they were massacred we should move the
churches off the land where the blacks
in Jamestown or Rosewood or the or uh
Tulsa Oklahoma were burned out because
they said they were Christians and so if
you're going to be sensitive on one hand
you should move all of the churches off
of the other areas where the Christians
have created M being compassionate I'm
talking about being compassionate be
compassionate are you willing to do that
oh come on look at 9/11 look at the
people that lost loved ones we all
suffered all around the United States
Amer I think you strain history for your
your analogy there Pamela though isn't
this the time to be kind isn't this the
time to lower our voices rather than
shout isn't this the time to reach out
and say let's get together and find a
solution that helps everybody that uh we
love the practice of organized religion
in this country we're founded on by
faithful people can't we do that can't
we work together we we can do that I
don't think the I don't think the who is
radical but how can we do that when you
have a group called stop the
islamization I stop the yeah stop the
islamization of America why do you see
that as divisive it's happening look at
because it's bizarre that you say that
it's not bizar look have you been to
Europe have you been to the Middle East
it was once a Christian continent what
I'm saying is in history most of the
Muslims in this country were born in
this country I think that many Muslims
ran from the Sharia in their country but
can we get back to the issue at hand for
a second can we discuss the last in what
in I mean the the 15 story Mega mosque
in a building that was hit by the
community center they say it's a
learning CER a mosque is a community
center but it is but it
is it's a 15 story middle finger to the
American people that's my point and no
it really you made your point where is I
got it I got ites gu one is does your
guess know I think it's time to learn do
does your guess know this should be
listen listen this should be a learning
experience do your guest know learning
let me make a point people go back let
me make a point let me make a point does
your guest know does your guest does
your guest know that presidents George
Washington and Thomas Jefferson were
Shriners who studied the Quran and Islam
because they were fighting it and and
ISL deeply
rooted so you should this should be an
opportunity this is an
opportunity stop no CH to learn Noel you
want to say something quick let's let's
just break it down really simple no one
is against building a mosque we don't
want it on ground zero that's enough
that's all we're asking you going to
have to deal couple blocks don't have to
deal a couple of blocks and we all sing
Kumbaya and I'll lead the parade I'll
even write a little check us stay with
the Donald thank you all everyone